a Bushmaster the largest pit viper in
the world has a bite so venomous that
humans have only a 25 percent survival
rate that is not good she can sense the
faintest chemical odors and vibrations
in her environment
she has detected prey would not want to
be said prey pit vipers are named for
the specialized organ that can detect
the body heat of other animals which
they use to pinpoint their victims she
uses her fangs to walk the prey into her
gullet that's our choice of a word they
didn't actually walk but you know
they're snakes we thought we thought
they'd like that she always starts head
first satiated she is ready to lay her
eggs and she will not eat again for
months
it's the perfect diet very efficient but
she will already be gone by the time
they hatch probably leaving these snakes
with abandonment issues without their
mother the young bushmasters will
venture out alone to find their first
meal there they go these emotionally
scarred motherless snakes forging their
own paths finding their own destiny
their place among the stars
good luck little Bushmaster this humble
narrator wishes them well
[Music]